so as many of you know we now are around
800,000 YouTube subscribers which is
absolutely awesome but I've told you
that there have been some sort of weird
things happening with our subscriber
numbers as well as our view counts
recommended views and all sorts of stuff
and one of the things we've noticed is
that the subscriber numbers are growing
way faster than views from subscribers
and in fact we are trying to figure out
why is it that so few of our subscribers
are seeing our videos and one of the
things that I found out when going over
our data over the weekend is that only
9% of our subscribers have notifications
turned on and only 5% of our subscribers
have both notifications on for our
channel and YouTube notifications turned
on and of course one is not going to do
much if you have notifications turned
off altogether so I want your help to
test this out I want people to turn on
notifications I'll report back to you
about how these numbers move from 9 and
5% in a few weeks and we'll also look at
whether our views from subscribers are
going up I think that there could be
something here that's very significant
so we have instructions linked below
about how to do this on desktop you go
into settings and notifications and on
mobile it's also under notifications and
subscriptions it's different depending
on the version and your device so we've
linked the instructions below again only
9% of our subscribers have notifications
on for our channel and 5 for our channel
and on their device let's bring that up
I'm asking for your help this could be a
really huge thing actually and helping
out one of the areas that this channel
has really been struggling in let's do
it I'll report back in a couple of weeks
tell you how the numbers have changed
and hopefully this will be a good thing